c'est pas ton fils là
[Musique]
c'est quoi cette vidéo vous avez fait
avec les garçons là un clip fait
polémique des images qui ont choqué
jusqu'au plus haute fonction de l'état
avec la plante du maire qui vont venir
pour nous enlever nos gosses avec eux on
a tout essayé on n'arrive pas à parler à
nos enfants et qu'il n'écoute que du rap
alors on va leur faire du rap
il faut dire ça tous les petits disent
sales tout le temps dit ça
je peux demander à ma nièce
je vous ai dit
je vais faire de vous des vrais
guerrières des grosses folles des
grosses
pardon c'est bon je serai plus
compliment
comme dans la Ligue 1
depuis quand une maman ça fait du rap
donc pour les en empêcher vous faites du
rap
quand j'arrive c'est pour débusquer les
talents
je vais faire de vous des stars je vais
vous monter en l'air
[Musique]